your top Feud video 3.7 million views
and it's how to build a home studio for
under 350 at what point did you package
what you know into an online course one
day I was planning on doing like a
massive series teaching the software Pro
Tools put them in a zip file got a
PayPal button and then emailed my list
and said hey I have this thing and I
called it Pro Tools bootcamp and I sold
it for 47 bucks some dude named Paul
bought this ZIP file and then he loved
it and then another person bought it and
another person bought it and I was like
huh somebody paid for digital copies of
videos and I could now sell these videos
forever that was when I understood
digital products I just had the vision
all of a sudden of like oh my gosh what
if I had more courses what if I had
bigger of an audience what if I could
sell these at higher price points and I
just got really excited about what was
possible using YouTube to drive leads to
my list to then offer them even more
in-depth paid training and that was way
more exciting to me than ad Revenue